we had Luke's return lay your hands we
had a lot of one word I need clarity
right now I have clarity complete
clarity and we had John Paul Jones
Harger this is your bachelorette recap
grab your glasses it's time for roses
and rose eh
hi everybody I'm Lauren Zima and we are
back yes we are back as in many of our
favorite men are back on the men tell
all and I am back to Rosie today because
we'd had a couple weeks of Chardonnay
which a heightened don't hate at all but
oh it just felt right to come back home
didn't it back to the studio back to the
Roses back to the men and JC my man
bought me a cup of glacier ice cubes
because I know some of you said hey we
actually missed the ice in your wine
well thank you thank you for the support
I like ice in my wine - and a glacier
ice cube wow it's just the perfect
combination because it gives you the ice
but it doesn't melt too quickly and how
about JC who freakin brings me ice to
work did we have good men here at the
men tell all let's discuss it also I
want to give a shout out to one more
good good man you may notice that we
have some beautiful real roses here on
the roses and Rose a said today these
are the most gorgeous flowers they have
ever received in my life and they were
sent to me by one Chris Harrison thank
you Chris Harrison
as for the anniversary of our first
conversation
I know tonight we're picking up where we
left off okay let's get into it we are
actually not starting with the mental
all as chris says things are gonna be a
little different this season we are
starting back in Greece we're gonna see
that return from another man question
mark our boy our boy Luke our boy Luke
he's not a boy whatever he's a boy okay
so we have Hannah and I will say this
dress is not my faith nor is this hair
but Hannah's my fave and guys after this
episode we are going to have to ban a
few words from the English language and
I will call them out as we go on we
can't hear them again we can't say them
again and I want to be crystal clear on
this that's the power of the
Bachelorette we have to strike words
from the English language we've used
them too much the question is did we
misunderstand them I don't want to be
misunderstood here we go okay
so it turns out that Jed and Peter and
Tyler still think Lucas coming but
Hannah's like that guy and by the way
drink every time Hannah drops an F on
this episode like that guy leave
take that guy Hanna says of Luke we
never have to see him again but then
he's vlogging drink for a vlog Luke is
vlogging everybody okay she doesn't
realize that I still love her camera
around Luke so Luke is saying things
that are very on-brand for Luke he says
that the problem is that Hanna thinks
there's no way I want to do is there any
more that he doesn't want to be with her
sadly the stage let me be absolutely
transparent she broke up with you okay
this is not okay he doesn't get it Jesus
I don't want to take the Lord's name in
vain and I don't want Luke to have
driven me to that but that's where I am
ironically Luke you've done what is
probably the opposite of your mission
frustrated people with your beliefs
drink every time Luke has no respect for
Hanna's thoughts or opinions he says
quote she's never told me she loves me
but I know she loves me honestly forget
the religion thing put aside that
religion is a part of this Luke Hanna
conundrum and that faith has become
entangled with our frustrations with
Luke the actual problem here is that
Luke doesn't think Hanna can think for
herself that's it
forget your church forget your Bible put
it all aside everybody respect other
people's thoughts opinions this is gonna
be tough so we might need to take some
nice breaks for positivity let's take a
break for positivity and drink for every
beautiful flower
one of my my my what I wanna go
hmm I hope Hannah gets a mighty good man
at the end of this actually I'm fine
with her being just a mighty good woman
on around how do you guys think it's all
gonna end I only got two more episodes
[Applause]
[Music]
so Luke comes back to the rose ceremony
and Hannah says no I don't want to talk
to you and know that you're not gonna
stay Hannah I'm gonna stand here all day
until you know you're not drink every
time Luke does not understand that it's
not about him
this is my heart we're talking about
here this is a relationship this is not
about your heart my heart isn't broken
yet cuz I'm still standing here and this
is an this isn't over for me yet oh my
god what all right
and oh my god Hey
moved the pedestal she moves the
pedestal with the roses did you talk to
oh my god Luke brings up Colson leave
kolten out of this even though he is the
one who invented bachelor nation
vlogging Luke do you guys and then oh my
god we get the moment we've seen the
teaser Tyler sink or what we did 20
minutes dude listen lay your hands on
yeah what are you in the
I love hearing Tyler say this so much
and I'm not supporting the threat of
physical violence but can we just put it
on lay your hands or what Oh Tyler Tyler
in a gray suit yeah why are you telling
her who she is bro anymore what is great
but what's even better is that Tyler
asks Hannah what she chose to do you
already said it
yeah let's go uh-huh cheers to Tyler and
oh my god Tyler is biting his lip well
[Applause]
and drink for every time someone just
randomly walks into the scene then we
have this guy going through the
background unclear who he is
anyone here and then Chris Harrison and
then what a man what a mighty good man
Chris Harrison
asks Hannah what she wants to choose
what do you want this is all up to you
Tyler and Chris both asking Hannah for
her decision instead of telling her what
it is something Luke has seemingly never
done can you seriously looking in the
eyes and tell me that you have complete
clarity and that you have no feelings
for me any longer I can okay that's all
you do okay finally Luke leaves hate
that guy
[Music]
[Applause]
and the music changes and the guys are
happy and Jude takes credit for Hanna's
realization about Luke saying she
finally listened to him she hears me but
just means she hears me and Peter says
he's proud of Hanna and calls her a bad
just so pat has feelings thank you it's
gonna be an amazing night okay now we're
back home it's the mantle Oh even though
we've already been hearing a lot of one
man telling is we start tonight with
Luke we're starting with Luke we have to
we have to we start with him and we have
some scattered applause here's the thing
I keep saying this I get it going on a
reality show being exposed to the world
for the first time in a brand new
environment is probably tough and a
person could come across how they might
not have intended so this moment was
Luke's chance to own everything to
apologize straight up and to save some
face with some grace do you guys think
you did that it's gonna be a no for me
dawg I just want everyone to be clear
that my actions are because I got
completely blindsided so Luke stands by
leaving the show over Hannah sex life he
ignores her point about choosing to look
past many of his sins and give him
chance after chance then Luke says to
Chris Harrison quote I'm trying to think
of how to put this so it's clear to you
I think I've had it but this so it's
clear to you yeah trust me babe he's
good
so guys this is when we know we've got
to retire the words the first word we
are retiring clarity we're gonna pray
for clarity you me just clarify it so
everyone can understand can you
seriously look me in the eyes and tell
me that you have complete clarity the
next word we are retiring closure we've
got to close the door on closure closure
closure or closure but you're not
leaving until I at least have closure
alright don't drink during all of Luke's
bizarre pauses what were you hoping for
and trust me guys I was at the taping
and in person it was even more torturous
why do you think Luke was pausing my
guess is that he was at home you know
the show's airing and that he's being
advised by people you should really
think before you speak Luke and so he's
trying to do that maybe even trying to
call upon something he's memorized in
his head so you know that he can really
be understood I don't want to be
misunderstood misunderstood
misunderstood Luke keeps saying that it
was so frustrating for him to be so
misunderstood Luke could you own things
for a moment and acknowledge that maybe
you weren't communicating clearly maybe
that was on you like do you guys
understand what I'm saying right now no
you didn't and that's not me okay it's
time for more wine Luke's been on the
stage for quite a minute and I think of
time there's more or why
okay how relationships work is through
communication
remember when Luke told Hannah that
relationships were about communication
well you we just started dating I still
love her I still want what's best for
her
sure sure you do you know what is really
evidence of that as the Twitter war you
started with her did you guys see Luke's
tweets shameless blog had two easy
online comm for the full breakdown
during last week's fantasy suites
episode Luke made a Twitter account just
to start a public war of words with
Hannah then told her that if she wanted
to talk she knew how to get ahold of him
do you feel like you made any mistakes
Chris asks Luke if he made any mistakes
and Luke says that he wouldn't change a
thing
if I could go back I wouldn't change a
thing so we might as well just stop
right here but the problem with a guy
like Luke is that he is frustrated so
many people that everybody wants a
chance to have their final say with him
and we do still need Hanna to come out
and you know what while Luke didn't
deserve to speak any more words to Hanna
and she didn't owe him anything
Hanna is owed one more conversation if
she wants it just let me just say this
where I'm coming from
yeah and then completely on-brand for
Luke backtracking Parker he then says he
would change a lot of what he did
obviously if I could go back I would
change a whole lot
pause over okay what's on a rescue
mission for him
Luke says he came to rescue Panda okay
let me let me back up
but then clarifies not like save her
soul ID Smith from from them rescuer
from the other guys that's not any
better it's so insulting he allegedly
came on the show to rescue her from guys
who she didn't even know Luke I mean and
every comment is just a backtrack I
didn't like that guy and I don't blame
him for that he says he doesn't blame
the guys for not liking him but then
says the problem with his but that says
the prob
I'm getting my tongue he's getting tied
over Luke's paw but then says the
problem was that they wouldn't accept
anything he did no on-camera off-camera
mmm neglected being disrespected and
then Devin comes out and Chris reminds
us who Devin is this is Deb and
everybody make some good points there's
a there are men that want an independent
strong woman and there are men that want
a woman that they can control another
long pause Luke it shouldn't take you
this long to think about your answer to
the question of whether you want a woman
who you would put in a glass case the
type of woman you want is someone you
can kind of put on the Shelf in a glass
case hold down when you need
this can say the answer should be now we
need our next incident please just bring
me back to positivity bringing me back
to positivity okay I like my shirt
that's positive silver linings playbook
with a good man Bradley Cooper Oh Luke
is shallow
that's the sequel okay do it I'm getting
off at the tangent Jesus Christ ah I do
want a woman ultimately Luke says he
wants an independent woman who makes
decisions for herself then says men are
supposed to lead women all doing man is
supposed to lead and guy the woman in
the relationship do you guys think Luke
wants an independent woman let me know
in the comments below use your own
thoughts and opinions and personal
decision-making skills to leave a
comment independently here without
anyone guiding or leading or making the
decision for you alright the guys are
here we don't remember all of them we're
missing some of them where's Kevin
remember him we got John Paul Jones did
we got Connor
we got carrot and we got Dylan back from
the dead okay Chris asks Luke why he
couldn't make things work with the guys
and he says he had Hanna in the bag I
had it in the bag and again but I'd
can't we you know what like I said now I
know why Hanna was driving some of the
f-bombs cuz Luke had driven her to that
point and that's where I am right now
how are you guys are you okay okay
I felt like we gave him a clear slate
just like we each gave each other clear
slate
he just went completely out of his Lane
shall I say Mike is here to call out
Luke and I didn't miss this Mike is so
good at slayage he is soft-spoken but he
is smart and he is savage and he's
saying these things about Luke just
straightforward straight up and now he
says that Luke's future wife will be a
prisoner I think that your future wife
is one of you a prisoner of you oh my
god
wanna give you the only compliment of
the night that you're gonna get just say
that I do respect you being here and
then Conner comes in and Connors being
like his real surfer bro self and then
Conner is savage and he says to Luke
just you man I completely do not accept
your apologies that you just gave
because 15 minutes ago when we're
backstage Chris asked you a very
respectful question would you change
anything you said no the guys don't
accept Luke's apology would you I think
in this case actions speak louder than
words and Luke's action is to backtrack
on his words so it's quite impossible to
accept this apology it's 2019 man and
then Dylan is back from the dead hi
Dylan just see some very smart things
you can't talk to a woman like that
simple is out is there hypocrisy there
and then Luke just told Chris Harrison
to think about what he was asking think
about what you're asking and Luke I
stood up out of my chair just like Tyler
stood up for Hannah okay but you know
what just like Tyler I'm gonna step back
because Chris Harrison has got this and
he is not fazed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but I think to project that faith onto
someone else isn't the right way to do
it all right
I forget this guy's name but he chose
Luke not to put his faith on other
people and that was smart so drink for
all the smart guys and then he says he
said his piece and then he keeps
speaking it hurts me to hear that yet
some of you don't accept my apology and
I want you to know that I'm sincere
sincerely sorry about how it played out
[Music]
ah John Paul Jones let's just be
positive from here on out John Paul
Jones he's in the hot seat he's looking
hot flipping that hair around at shears
for him and his great posture in the hot
seat and drink for every time JPJ was so
humble and credited his newfound fame
with someone else wouldn't have been
easy to have burnout if you guys weren't
so easy to get along with so uh you know
all the attention you know that I've
gotten is you know tributed to you guys
thank you and don't drink for every
chicken nugget there were a lot they
were back there were so many you threw
them into the crowd glad he liked them
can't wait to watch on my paradise and
drink for Chris Harrison's adorable
laugh during all that Big Mike oh and
then Mike's in the hot seat and cheers
to Mike and bang Mike looks good even
Chris Harrison acknowledged that he was
a bit of a smoke show look at you man
you're throwing smoke today oh my person
well looking good got that smile cheers
to Mike then mike says the reason is
there it's learn how to become a better
man but I continue grow as a man I'm
grounding positivity train
[Applause]
Hana comes out and Hana looks gorgeous
I'm Hannah thanks the guys I'm just so
blessed to have had you on this ride
with me and she makes a lot of good
points there is this huge fear of what
your intentions are when she became the
Bachelorette the guys didn't know who
the Bachelorette would be and so she
wondered if they were there for fame for
their careers that night Luke made me
believe that he was there for me but
notes that perhaps that's why she had
such a strong connection with Luke
because Luke did indicate that he was
very clearly there for Hannah helpful
context Anna honestly did I sit around
being like huh Who am I gonna have sex
with in the fantasy suite
so Hannah's confronting Luke and talking
about how you know Luke asked her about
her sex life on camera and it wasn't
your business to ever ask me and I just
thought about this you guys it is just
so invasive to me it really hasn't been
done on the show before but Luke asked
Hannah who she'd slept with on camera on
the night of the fantasy suite he had
with her he could have asked her that in
private off-camera later and now I'm
even more clearly okay Luke leaves
criticized to catch a flight to the fly
truly that's why he left he instagrammed
about being at a wedding the next day
and also that's why we weren't able to
interview him at the mental all because
he had to leave to catch a flight either
we hoped her if you look at some point I
really do you guys don't ask a lot of
freaking questions I really wanted to
ask him a lot a question was that not it
really really did
okay what questions do you have for Luke
let me know in the comments below then
unlike Luke Hanna gives an apology that
is straight up
that is her owning the things she did
that involves no backtracking she
apologizes to America I just wanted to
say bachelor nation I'm sorry him just
being on our television screens for so
long for keeping Luke on our television
screens so long oh my god you guys time
for our first ever roses and roses style
vlog guess what JC has been inspired by
this season
Tyler C and Lucas Newsies dressing JC
Tyler C yes in those tight pants in a
fabulous colorful jacket moment
[Applause]
[Music]
and we have the trailer for the finale
aunt Anna isn't eating Anna is fully oh
my god Hannah we are here to pick you up
away you don't need as I'm sure you can
pick yourself up girl Hannah we adore
you I cannot wait for this to Night Live
finale the Bachelorette have you guys
ever anticipated a live finale so much
we have to get answers still about Jed
how about Peter what will happen a Tyler
or what oh my god you guys I had to vlog
about bachelor in paradise what a promo
what a trailer Demi and a lady yes up
first for the franchise I love it I love
her and then dared pytheas crying and oh
my god some kind of physical altercation
and OH John Paul Jones fighting with
Derek pet and more crying than ever
before and John Paul Jones crying is
this gonna be the best season of
paradise ever I love you guys so much
thank you so much as always for watching
please leave your thoughts and comments
again your thoughts and comments in the
comment section below I am on Cameo if
you want to book me for a cameo I adore
you
bye e Oh JC I just realized you gave me
two ice cubes you got a first one and
then you did it a second time
[Music]